[拍手]
みなさんは自分自身の力で
積んでいる地域を盛り上げることは可能だと思いますか
僕は可能だと思います
僕は遠坂地域活性化委員会を立ち上げ
チキンに3回夏はゴミ拾い
悟りを道や公園整備
冬は雪価値や塩カル待つと
多し活動を中心に活動してきました
今までに何回か新聞や広報誌などに取り上げられ
取材を受けたことがあります
そうしたときなぜ奉仕活動をするのまだ中学生なのに
と聞いてくる人がいました
また友達の多くはこんな田舎はやだ
将来は東京に行くと言っています
なぜ奉仕活動をするのか
なぜここでしたいのか
その理由は積んでいると大阪が大好きでいいいいところだと思っているからです
そしてこの地域がきれいになっていくのが嬉しいからです
僕たちは小学生の頃から地域のために何かがしたいとずっと考えていました
小学5年生の頃僕たちの帰っていた学校では
学校内で会社を立ち上げ手作りのものを得るという活動が流行っていました
当時学校ではエコキャップ運動が実施されており僕もキャップを集めてみましたがこの
環境活動と地域を繋げたらちょうど良いと思いエコキャップと引き換えに商品を交換
する
ふくふく度というお店を立ち上げました
このお店で僕は
豊栄おすすめガイドブックを作成し販売しました
この頃からとても素敵なこの地域をもっとみんなに知ってもらいたいと思っていました
その他にも福々堂では調節や絵本を作り販売しました
しかし本がたくさん売れて生徒たちが読書の時間まで
品福堂の本を読んでいると先生たちが
おかしい女もな本じゃないなどと言って送り出しました
そして品だけでなく福々堂の活動までも否定されてしまいました
学校では
自分たちがみんなのため地域のために活動することに対し
先生たちに指定されたことが何度かあります
僕はこの頃同じ院富田君と一緒に
放送敬仁会の正副委員長を務めていました
毎年恒例のクラッシュ紹介ビデオという企画を行っていた時のことです
毎年必ず実施していた企画だったのに新しい先生にやる意味がないなどと言われ僕たち
は反論をしました
けれどもそれは通用せず楽しみにしていた生徒もいたはずなのに
大衆的には実施を断念しました
また
小学生の頃からずっとやりたいと思っていたのはマラソン大会です
しかしこれも企画途中で先生につかり危険だからやめろ
県はどうするんだなると言われ僕たちは反論することも出ず
実証断念しました
すでに準備を進めていきたい先だったので本当に悔しかったです
それでもずっとマラソン大会を開催したいと考えていました
先生やお隣危険だやめろ
なると言われていろいろなことを断念してきたけれども
やはり自分が信じて実行しようと思ったことは誰が何を言おうとやり遂げようと思う
ようになりました
そこで地域活性化を持っていくとして立ち上げた
どうせか地域活性化委員会でマラソン大会を実行させると決意しました
今年の1月ごろに本格的に実行が決定しメンバーも増え
就任3回話し合いや準備を進めてきました
僕はちょうど松代地区社会福祉協議会で働いているし田村さんという方と知り合いだっ
たことから
真っ白地区住民自治協議会及び松商地区社会福祉協議会にご協力をお願いし
実際に運営費などの樹勢や広報などの面でご協力をいただきました
また町ロ地区の多くの方々にボランティアとして支援していただきました
そして今年の4月30日念願だった
マラソン大会を無事成功させることができました
ずっとやりたいと考え結果考えているいたことだったから成功させることができて
とても嬉しかったです
またて元にもなく運営できたことにとても達成感を感じました
同日はうまくいかないこともありましたが参加ランナーは80名
ボランティア50名大江約20メートル
あわせて150名にも及ぶ人々が楽しさかに集まり
世代間での交流ができ地域活性会の確かな一歩となりました
car
[拍手]
[音楽]
マラソン大会は終わりましたが活性化委員会としての活動はこれからも続いていきます
大変なのはむしろこの立つ委員のメンバーをまとめたりもっと仕事をしてほしい
取材にで投資なんと説得するのは納得しないメンバーも多く大変です
また活性化委員会への取材や発表会が増えて本来の目的地域活性化ということを見失う
ことも多いです
それでも続けたいみんなからはすごいねって言われるけれど
僕はただ普通にこの中金が好きで仲間がいるから
活動ができるのです
うまくいかないことも多いけれど何もしないよりかは良い
継続していけば何か見えてくるはずと思い活動を続けています
俺えっ同社が地域活性化委員会のメンバーを紹介します
[拍手]
本来は活性化委員会は6人で活動しておりますが本日来ているのは当委員会へ後方防災
課の富田君です
[拍手]
僕たちは済んでいると大阪が大好きです
だからこの町のために活動を続けています
豊栄はスーパーもないし学校から帰るのも自転車で30分以上もかかる
小さな田舎町です
しかし美しい自然に囲まれてどれだけ探検しても新しい発見でいっぱいです
人々は親切で温かいです
そんな素敵なと大阪を守りが自生地活性化させることが僕たちの夢です
最後になりますが何かをやろうと考えている方へ
考えているだけでは何も始まりません
確かに反対する人も出てくるかもしれません
最初から大きなことをするのではなく初めのうちはゴミ拾いのような小さなことから
始めてみてはどうでしょうか
何かをやろうという気持ちは実際に行動に移すべきです
信念を持って継続すれば必ずできると思いますありがとうございました
[拍手]